[Music]
and uh trended societies and i mean in a
way snapchat has also challenged you a
little bit at the beginning by uh
focusing on a more ephemeral
product here
but my question is i mean i remember
when we have met first time in 2006 in
berlin
uh clearly you were not very focused on
privacy i fully understand the man you
just watched lecture sentient robot is
matthias dochner the ceo of axel
springer which is one of the largest
media companies on the planet it's a
european publishing house that owns some
of the most circulated european
newspapers and owns a stake in multiple
recognized brands in 2015 it bobbed
business insider at a 442 million
valuation which also eventually gave
them access to morning brew one of the
most successful american business
newsletters with over 3 million
subscribers
springer was also the joint owner of
politico eu and just the day before
yesterday it was announced that they
would also buy politico us for one
billion dollars putting a european
company in charge of one of the most
influential washington news
organizations
springer's reach in europe mainly stems
from its ownership of two german media
outlets the build and developed the
build is the most circulated european
tabloid and has often been criticized
for being sensationalized while the
latter develt is a highly circulated
more sober conservative newspaper
besides owning a number of brands what
makes springer unique is that it is a
european media company that instead of
failing in the digital revolution
prospered with the advent of the
internet digital content increased and
publishing houses faced serious cutbacks
and revenue as their main source of
capital newspapers declined for example
in 2014 el pais one of spain's daily
newspapers saw its advertising income
drop by around 60
and they responded by firing nearly one
third of their workforce
these trends were near universal and
multiple european countries saw dramatic
reductions in newspaper publishing
revenues although axel springer did
initially lose revenue unlike others
they adapted but if you look at for
instance the new york times the new york
times has been wonderfully successful in
the digital newspaper
and yet their revenues from digital the
growth of revenues from digital
advertising does not match
the the decline in circulation and
advertising for the print newspaper okay
how do you get more than one-tenth how
do you get such a large rate of return
well i need to be very to be very clear
through a quite dramatically changed
portfolio i mean we sold most of our
newspapers we sold most of our
magazines we basically sold our entire
print portfolio and we replaced it
through fast growing digital assets
hadn't we done that would we simply
basically reduced to our original
portfolio our
p l our revenue structures would look
completely different
the company would be probably a no
growth or negative growth company and
would still be largely dominated by a
sharply declining print business dopner
led a charge to focus on paid content
marketing in the classified ad business
under his lead the company was ruthless
and selling off different badly
performing newspapers and he pushed
heavily for increasing investment in
digital content which set the groundwork
for a future revenue stream that would
mainly be driven by digital
subscriptions when at first digital
subscriptions made little to no revenue
at all
dopner also engaged in somewhat
unconventional tactics like sending
german executives to silicon valley to
learn from american entrepreneurs the
combination of all these changes meant
that axel springer saw growth in its
stock price and revenue whereas others
went bankrupt or relied on expensive
donors in 2021 axel springer's purchase
of politico us also represents the bet
that the european media company is
making for the future that english
content has a larger potential for scale
and the digital content cannot survive
off of advertising alone and media
companies with loyal subscription
followings are the future of sustainable
publications
[Music]
[Music]
you